[Music]
what's up guys we're pon Finiti we're
back on our tables and it's rough to do
lake trick shots too let's go
[Music]
so we use these to get here now let's
see if we can play with them ready yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the middle is the best part oh I forgot
that I have I'm sorry
[Music]
paddle master ooh
so cold I could see the table I don't
recommend you to try this the whole ears
full of water that's okay
[Music]
yes one more one more
this guy he's been in there for half an
hour and he just wants more okay
[Music]
yes
Oh
you haven't subscribe to our channel yet
please do it right now for more of these
kind of content well no more I didn't
even see that it passed the table
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think your racket was a bit wet
no that one looks so good that looks so
promising did it go on yes see one
[Music]
good job Mika I think it's time to go
fishing
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
all right it's time for the back with
table ten shot jump and hit at the same
time ready yeah just watch out for the
edge that was a good one of the best one
so far
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh cool there's like ten centimeters oh
come on Michael I've got so much water
in my ears not even here you forgot the
bakflip it's not gonna work I'm not
gonna get do one more try
okay that's not if you hear subscribe
I'll practice my water backflip and one
day we'll get this shot on picking up
some balls
yeah got those fishing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I love that pad
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so the Sun has set it's 10:30 p.m. and
we're ready to take a sauna okay let's
pick the balls and go home so if this
video hits 30,000 likes we'll be back
next year with a even bigger even better
table - this runs until next time I
promise I'll get this shot on I hope you
next time